and we gotta take care of each other
so if you see somebody that's hurting
its own look away and if you're hurting
even though it might be hard try to find
that bravery within yourself to dive
deep and go tell somebody and take them
up in your head with you I love you
thank you so much to the Grammy Awards
the superstar has spoken openly about
dealing with mental illness including
depression anxiety and PTSD her mother
Cynthia Germanotta who looks just like
her rather Gaga looks like her mom joins
us now to talk about the impact of
mental illness on family and friends
Germanotta teamed up with her daughter
who she calls stephanie that's her name
also known as Lady Gaga - the rest of us
to create the Born This Way Foundation
it works to educate people about mental
and emotional wellness cynthia german
Germanotta thank you for joining us for
having me because I'm inspired by you
focusing on that thank you
we're delighted to do this you know Gaga
has talked very openly about it and you
were said you know when she was a kid
you always knew she was unique when did
it go from unique - houston we have a
problem at your house well yeah well
first you know we all have mental health
but I believe that we as both
individuals in society we don't treat it
the same way that we treat physical
health yes so certainly when it happened
in our house I didn't know what to look
for as a parent I wasn't prepared to
really address this Stephanie was very
unique and that wasn't always
appreciated by her peers and as a result
she went through a lot of difficult
times
humiliated taunted isolated when you're
a young woman this really severely
impacts you and it was in middle school
when I saw that turn happen you know
when she went from a very happy and
aspirational young girl to somebody that
started to question her self-worth to
have doubts about herself and and that
is when we actually saw the turn what I
didn't realize because I wasn't prepared
is how to really deal with it yeah when
I was growing up times were different
the way that we would deal with things
is what I learned and that's what I
resorted to you know
Lyde on get a grip I relied on getting a
grip I relied on the generational grit
of just sucking it up and getting on
with it but even if even if you you do
learn to listen sometimes it's still
very hard and I've been in this
situation to know what to do it's very
hard to know what to do and then the
impact on families what I didn't realize
is the profound impact that it can have
it basically turns the focus of
everything onto that one individual and
families feel conflicted about it they
don't really understand it it causes
conflict and a lot of stress within the
families it can also cause feelings for
me personally feelings of guilt of
helplessness not knowing how to help my
daughter so what I really learned is
that no family is immune from this we
should all really learn all really learn
you know where we would go and who we
would turn to if something like this
happened in our families now that you've
been through it you've come out the
other side what advice or
recommendations you have to other people
who right now may have a family member
going through this very thing well one
of the most difficult things for me as a
parent was understanding what was normal
and what was not normal when you look at
young children in particular you know
what is normal adolescent development
and then a real issue and that for me
was was not knowing how to distinguish
between certain both emotional and
behavioral changes you know your
emotions there's very noticeable changes
that happen feelings of sadness feelings
of feeling selfless and worthless in
terms of behavior you might be more
angry crying turning to substance abuse
yeah what wouldn't I recommend yeah
what's the most important thing a parent
can do well the most important thing
that they can do is is really listen and
understand what I learned from my
daughter is to listen and validate her
feelings I think as parents our natural
instinct is to go into problem-solving
mode ya know relatable yet when in fact
you know they really just want us to
take them seriously and understand what
they're saying and sometimes they don't
often want to talk to their parents or
talk to their peers it's it important to
find somebody that they can talk to AP's
they're not talking to you we've learned
from our research that young people
often don't turn to their
you know their parents because they feel
we get on their nerves yes there's fear
of being judged yeah also we as parents
we don't talk about our own struggles I
encourage parents to be vulnerable talk
about your current or past struggles so
it really models healthy conversations
and and good behavior yes the biggest
thing is to really talk to them and it's
it's certainly okay to not be okay and
start to have these conversations right
Cynthia Germanotta thank you so much for
coming
[Applause]